We have all heard of mind over matter, but
is it possible that the right motivation can
actually help repair spinal damage?I have
come to Lausanne, Switzerland to find out
about some innovative research being done
to repair the spinal cords of rats using pharmaceuticals,
electrical signals.
And the key ingredient?
Motivation.
Sometimes with the right motivation anything
is possible.
Tres bien.
The main function of the spinal cord is to
transmit neural signals or messages between
the brain and the rest of the body.
So when the spinal cord is severed or crushed,
these messages can’t get past the injury.
The result is often chronic paralysis.
Research in this area generally focuses on
regenerating damaged nerve fibers, but here
in Lausanne they are taking a different approach.
>> Bonjour, Derek.
>> Bonjour.
>> Welcome in the lab.
>> Ah, thank you.
>> Professor Courtine’s work with rats is
producing remarkable results.
>> So I thought, what can we actually deliver
to the spinal cord the kind of information
that the brain would deliver naturally in
order to walk.
>> The rats have their spinal cord’s cut
in two places.
Although not completely severed, signals can’t
get past the legion, leaving the rats paralyzed.
To reactivate the healthy, but disconnected
neural cells below the injury, the researchers
administer a cocktail of synthetic neural
transmitters followed by electrical stimulation.
>> I am cutting the cable that connects to
the electrodes on the spinal cord so we can
provide the stimulation to the spinal cord.
>> Ok.
So there are cables that run down the spinal
cord?
>> It actually runs under the skin and then
it is sutured on top of the spinal cord.
>> This electro-chemical combination mimics
the input of the brain and reawakens the spinal
cord below the lesion.
>> Now I start the 20 immediately.
Oh, as soon as that is working.
It is amazing, right?
>> The result?
After a few weeks of training and while on
the treadmill, the rat is incredibly able
to walk again.
>> So this animal was completely paralyzed
five minutes ago and now she is doing  stepping
on the treadmill.
And now we have got 20 speed.
Even got the... the animal is capable of  on
the treadmill.
And look at this.
You can let him do it yourself.
I would stop the treadmill.
Oh, she stands immediately.
>> But this is happening without the involvement
of the brain.
At this stage the rat’s stepping is stimulated
by the treadmill.
The legs are moving independently of the brain,
so the movement is completely involuntary.
>> You can train rats on this treadmill for
two months.
You will not see recovery of voluntary control.
Why?
The brain is not involved.
There is no motivation to work, because we
see that the rat...
>> Motivation is the key to restoring voluntary
movement.
So this is when the irresistible Swiss chocolate
comes in.
I brought a chocolate éclair . I ate half,
but the other half is for the rat.
>> Yes, eat.
>> she does like it.
>> She likes it.
>> We have a combination of like actually
yogurt and chocolate which the rat love.
>> This reward based training without a treadmill
was the focus of the next phase of research.
>> I have to get her in the right position.
>> They designed a special robot which only
supports the paralyzed rat, but doesn’t
propel it forward.
>> This means that the rats really need to
generate the propulsive forces to go to the
reward, which is the chocolate.
>> So the rat is asked to go and to push herself
forward.
But she does get a little bit of help up and
down.
>> So the rats have, again, been given electric
chemical stimulants, but without the treadmill
the rat has to decide for itself if it wants
to walk.
>> When you want the animal to participate
very actively, I mean, we are talking about
the championships of rehabilitation, you know?
You need to motivate the rat at any cost.
>> Come, come, come, come, come.
>> So Rubia does whatever it takes to coax
the rat to walk.
>> Come on, jump, go forwards.
Come on.
Push, then push.
Push it.
Push and come on.
>> Go, go, go, go, go, go.
>> Come on.
Keep going.
>> The rat is now walking when it wants to,
which means the brain’s signals are getting
through to the previously paralyzed limbs.
>> Wow, she has done really well.
>> Yeah.
>> The rat’s spinal cord seems much more
capable of rewiring itself than anyone expected.
In one of the most extensive examples observed,
it has been able to detour around the injury
and reconnect the dormant neural network.
>> What we observe is that the cut fibers,
basically, they grow and deliver to this  injury
enough information.
We don’t know what kind, but sufficient
information from the brain to have voluntary
control.
>> What we are hearing is evidence of the
rat making the decision to walk.
The popping sound is a neuron firing.
And here she is just standing, but you will
see once she starts walking there is a pretty
clear pattern of the activity of the neuron
with the rat stepping.
>> It is showing that the movement is voluntary.
>> That is really cool.
That was really exciting the first time that
happened, because, you know, we had this idea
that the brain should be involved, but it
hadn't been proven.
>> Go, go, go.
>> There is a whole team of people working
and everybody is pushing the rat and everybody
is all go, go, go.
And I could hear it before it happened.
And I really knew, ok, it is going to work
this time.
>> Perfect.
>> Wow.
With half of all human spinal injuries leading
to chronic paralysis, Professor Courtine’s
research gives new hope to those affected.
>> So, of course, the next obvious and, you
know, exciting goal is to try this type of
intervention in humans.
I don’t know, it is difficult to say what
this will achieve in humans.
But, you know, it is a very promising new
path.